und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend zumindest biografisch nähert
sich frankreichs präsident makro der
ukraine schon mal an mit rumänien und
moldau bereist er heute und morgen zwei
nachbarländern von dort ist es dann
nicht mehr weit nach kiew das verstärkt
die erwartungen dass man kann dort bald
zusammen mit kanzler scholz eintrifft
leichter gespräche würden das nicht
präsident seelands gerhard ihrem heute
journal gestern ja seine kritik an der
zögerlichkeit deutschlands und
frankreichs nochmal deutlich formuliert
und im donbass läuft den ukrainern die
zeit davon reif kann jack berichtet
auf einmal heißt es rennen nur noch
rennen irgendwie raus während der
beschuss immer näher kommt
die villa 20 kilometer nördlich von
cervelo netz bewaffnete ukrainische
polizisten sind ihre letzte hoffnung
wenige sind es die noch hier sind
[Applaus]
danke an die polizei dass sie hilft die
menschen zu retten es gibt keine anderen
möglichkeiten heute die evakuierungs
busse können die stadt nicht erreichen
da sie geschossen werden
unter lebensgefahr versucht die
ukrainische nationalpolizei die menschen
irgendwie raus zu schaffen
[Applaus]
nach eigenen angaben sind es 32 menschen
die sich hier aus der region retten
konnten die seit tagen unter heftigen
beschuss liegt evakuierungen hier
eigentlich kaum noch möglich vor allem
weil mittlerweile alle brücken zerstört
wurden zwischen der hart umkämpften
stadt sirte netz und ließ sich chance
noch ukrainisch kontrolliertem gebiet
russland hat den verbliebenen kämpfern
heute ein ultimatum zur kapitulation
gestellt
auch wenn sich die heftigsten kämpfe
mittlerweile im osten des landes
konzentrieren die wunden und das leid
des krieges sind überall im land zu
spüren
trauerfeier flexicapture einer der
vielen toten des krieges der soldat und
journalist starb vor wenigen tagen
unsere kinder unsere so gut aber es
kostet sehr sehr viel auch menschen
leben
gekommen höhere verluste wir haben keine
andere wollen den kampf um den donbass
bezeichnete präsident zielinski heute
als einen der brutalsten in der
geschichte europas
das interview von christian sievers mit
kiews bürgermeister vitali klitschko
können sie nachher im heute-journal
update 10 oder auf zdf heute online
abrufen
und dann schauen wir nach großbritannien
trainer boris johnson steht
innenpolitisch ziemlich unter druck auch
in seiner eigenen partei rumort es also
versucht johnson in die offensive zu
gehen und seine anhänger mit
aufsehenerregenden aktionen zufrieden zu
stellen dazu gehört zum einen dass er
ankündigt die rexit verträge mit der eu
in teilen ignorieren zu wollen was
erhebliche konsequenzen haben kann nicht
nur für nordirland und er will
asylsuchende verschiedenster herkunft
nach ruanda abschieben über dieses
wanderprogramm soll sich sogar prinz
charles entsetzt geäußert haben aus
london andreas stamm
ein flug so umstritten wie teuer 130
flüchtlinge sollten ursprünglich an bord
mit ziel rohren dagegen höchstens sieben
werden es sein für 600.000 euro die
anderen haben sich schon mit eilanträgen
gegen die abschiebung werden können
unterdessen kommen weiter flüchtlinge an
im vergangenen jahr fast 30.000 nun gilt
wer auf diesem illegalen weg kommt kann
ausgeflogen werden darf nur in ruanda
asyl beantragen was selbst bei einem
positiven bescheid heißt endstation
ostafrika keine legale möglichkeit mehr
nach großbritannien zu kommen dafür
überweist die britische regierung
hunderte millionen nach kigali setzt auf
abschreckung
was die schleuser tun ist versuchter
totschlag am ort überfahrten über den
ärmelkanal 'nicht seetüchtigen booten
dieses geschäftsmodell müssen wir
stoppen
proteste und kritik sind heftig asyl
auszulagern breche internationales recht
25 englische bischöfe verurteilen die
praxis in einem offenen brief als
unmoralisch eine schande für das land
die vereinten nationen weisen auf die
schwierige menschenrechtslage in ruanda
hin faire asylverfahren sei nur schwer
zu garantieren
alles daran ist falsch vor allem wenn es
sich um einen erstunterzeichner der
genfer flüchtlingskonvention handelt der
über die mittel verfügt mit dem problem
klar zu kommen es sei die festung
britannien erklärt der syrer ibrahim in
einem telefonat in einer abschiebe
einrichtung wartet er auf den flug er
wollte zu frau und kind die schon in
london sind doch eine legale route aus
kriegs und krisengebieten gebe es für
fast niemanden was menschenrechtler
bestätigen ebenso dass die flüge kaum
abschrecken
wenn sie mich nach ruanda schicken werde
ich wiederkommen bis ich bei meiner
familie bin wird mich nicht aufhalten
ich bin bereit dafür zu sterben
ibrahim ist nicht mehr auf der
passagierliste nach zehn juristischem
tauziehen das weitergeht bis kurz vor
dem geplanten start in knapp einer
stunde denn eilanträge die gerade vor
dem europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte verhandelt werden könnten
den flug doch noch stoppt
das von donald trump eine gefahr für die
amerikanische demokratie ausgehen würde
davor haben viele von anfang an gewarnt
doch dass seine amtszeit am ende so
eskalieren würde hat selbst seine
schärfsten gegner fassungslos gemacht
der blutige sturm aufs kapital ein
versuchter staatsstreich weil der mann
nicht akzeptieren konnte war es ja der
kern jeder echten demokratie ist dass
man abgewählt werden kann das jump seine
anhänger mit der mär vom wahlbetrug auf
hetzte er dann sogar einige seiner
eigenen leute bestürzt auch das bringt
der untersuchungsausschuss in washington
zu tage von dort berichtet benjamin
daniel
12 seiten umfasst das statement von
donald trump zur untersuchung der
capitol erstürmung zwölf seiten auf
denen nichts haltbares steht keine
substanzielle gegendarstellung kein
entkräften der beweise lediglich die
bekannten lügenmärchen allen voran jenes
der angeblich gestohlenen wahl
auch nach der zweiten öffentlichen
ausschusssitzung ist schwer zu begreifen
dass die republikaner ihrem anführer das
alles weiter durchgehen lassen denn es
wird immer deutlicher dass selbst
charmes engster kreis von anfang an
abstand von seinen wahlsieg fantasien
haben
ich war demoralisiert und dachte mir oh
weh wenn er dieses zeug wirklich glaubt
dann muss er den bezug zur realität
verloren haben
ich war damals und heute davon überzeugt
dass die wahl nicht gestohlen
bei der anhörung kam auch heraus dass
trump seine anhänger und 250 millionen
dollar betrogen haben soll spendengelder
die er angeblich für
rechtsstreitigkeiten benutzen wollte
die jump kampagne hat die falschen
wahlbetrugs behauptungen dafür benutzt
um hunderte millionen dollar an spenden
zu sammeln sie haben behauptet das geld
für gerichtliche auseinandersetzungen zu
benutzen haben sie aber nicht die große
lüge war also auch eine große abzocke
die aufarbeitung des 6 januar 2021 geht
also weiter am ende könnten die
ergebnisse auch grundlage für einen
strafprozess gegen jump seien in jedem
fall ist schon jetzt klar die
trennlinien zwischen wahrheit und lügen
werden immer deutlicher
und jetzt kann's wolf in den nachrichten
der krieg in der ukraine ist auch eine
bedrohung für die getreideversorgung in
teilen der welt der deutsche
bauernverband will deshalb auch
hierzulande mehr produzieren
verbandspräsident rukwied warb auf dem
bauerntag in lübeck dafür vorübergehend
zusätzliche flächen zu nutzen
gazprom germania laut bundesregierung
ein schlüsselunternehmen für die
gasversorgung in deutschland soll mit
einem milliarden schweren darlehen vor
der pleite gerettet werden anfang april
hatte der bund die kontrolle über die
deutsche tochter des russischen
staatskonzerns übernommen und der
russische gazprom konzern kürzt die
maximale liefermenge nach deutschland
durch die ostsee pipeline nord stream 1
um 40 prozent gazprom nennt als grund
verzögerungen bei reparaturarbeiten vom
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hieß es die
versorgungssicherheit sei aktuell
gewährleistet
der schlagzeuger der puhdys klaus
scharfschwerdt ist gestorben im alter
von 68 jahren an krebs von 1979 an war
er mitglied bei den puhdys eine der
erfolgreichsten bands der ddr
[Musik]
die wetteraussichten morgen im norden
bei 18 bis 25 grad wolkig sonst meist
sonnig und höchstwerte zwischen 25 und
33 grad am donnerstag bei 20 bis 32 grad
oft freundlich und südosten allerdings
auch schauer und gewitter freitag und
samstag viel sonne und trocken und bis
zu 37 grad heiß
das war's auch schon von uns weiter geht
es mit der zweiten halbzeit oder um 0.45
gibt es dann unsere heutigen update mit
nazan guckte mir auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]